in house of cards you paint a picture of
a company that took on huge amounts of
leverage was run by a dysfunctional and
sometimes sparring family of executives
who seemed blind almost to the risks
that they were taking how did Baer get
it so wrong well I mean you have to I
think take it apart a little bit and say
you know did Warren Spector not
understand what was going on he was the
man who ran the fixed-income business
which as you know generated about 90% of
the revenues of the firm I think that he
probably understood exactly the risks
that they were taking the leverage that
the firm took on and then there was the
executive committee of four other people
in including Warren Spector Jimmy Kane a
screen burg Allen Schwartz and Sam Ilan
are the CFO now Jimmy told me and he was
the CEO from 1993 to 2008 that he was
not good enough as he said not smart
enough or not clever enough not
insightful enough to realize the amount
of risks that the firm was taking on and
he didn't really understand these
securities which is you know a nice
admission of sorts and I think that's I
appreciated that when he said it and I
believe that he believes it but on the
other hand I find it absolutely an
unbelievable that bear would have in
place a CEO paying him 30 40 million
dollars a year and have him not
understand the risks that the firm was
taking on and the kinds of securities
that the firm was taking on and you know
maybe the blame for that belongs with
the board of directors who should have
been a little more aggressive about you
know putting in place a CEO who did
understand those things there seem to be
warning signs though I mean Bear Stearns
had these hedge funds that imploded why
did nobody sort of heed those warning
signs or were there were there things
they could have realized from that
implosion that would have maybe avoided
the fate that they ultimately faced all
right it's a very good question because
the hedge funds their decisions
regarding the hedge funds I think really
put them in an additionally precarious
position so about in the spring of 2007
you know the hedge funds had been
rolling along they had about 40 months
in a row of positive returns on the
hedge funds
everybody was lauding Ralph Cioffi and
Matthew to mean the to hedge fund
managers as heroes and then in the
spring of 2007 the mark started to come
down on the value of the Securities in
the funds and at one point in April of
2007 they got they reported that the nav
had actually the net asset value of the
funds had fallen about 6% for that month
which is not good by any stretch of the
imagination and was basically one of the
first or second times that the fund had
lost value in a month but a week later
Goldman Sachs came back with revised
marks their marks about the fund about
the value of the securities and the fund
and instead of being at you know 99 98
97 Goldman's Mark's worth 50 cents on
the dollar which you know they rechecked
again as is required by the SEC but
Goldman stood by their marks and the
rest of the market stood by their marks
so then they have to average the marks
together they ended up having to reissue
their nav to investors and it was down
19.6% so it went down from minus 6
percent to minus close to 20 percent and
that was as one Bear Stearns executive
told me game set match for the funds now
the bear then made the fateful decision
later on in June to essentially replace
the overnight lenders to the fund the
so-called repo lenders to the fund with
their own financing from Bear Stearns at
that point
Bear Stearns had only a forty five
million dollar equity investment in the
funds you know a lot of money for sure
but not the end of the world for Bear
Stearns they then decided against Jimmy
Caine's wishes to be fair to him to put
to replace the the repo lenders take on
a billion and a half dollars worth of
overnight lending or law or short-term
lending to the fund and of course that
became a very fateful decision within a
month when they decided to liquidate the
funds they took all that collateral that
it was secured the loans that secured
and that collateral became worthless as
well and that you know that's what
resulted in the big loss that Bear
Starnes had in the fourth quarter of
2007 which was the first time the firm
had had a loss in its 84 year history to
step back for a minute unfortunately the
problems that befell Bear Sterns have
become very common in the financial
sector we've seen Lehman Brothers filed
for bankruptcy Bank of America and
Citigroup need government bailouts what
happened here what would what were these
companies betting on it was a real
estate market it sort of explained for
people watching how it went from being
something of a boom to something of a
bust was it the same thing that's caused
people at home to see their property
values decline you know they make risky
bets at bears just like people did you
know buying houses they couldn't fit yes
never it's actually an element of that
as well I mean I think you have to
probably go back to a policy decision
made by the Clinton administration to
encourage homeownership which is you
know part of the American Dream right so
the Clinton administration decided that
that was a good thing and basically
homeownership in this country had
averaged around 62 percent of households
owned their own homes the Clinton
administration you know got on the
bandwagon and started trumpeting that
people should increase their
homeownership so that increased over
time to about 67 percent and the Bush
administration jumped on that bandwagon
- so is this continuum of homeownership
well that Delta that difference of about
five percentage points was probably
around three million new homeowners some
of whom you know could afford to get a
mortgage to buy their home some of whom
could not but got them the mortgage
anyway because of fraudulent behavior
and the mortgage lending business and
this volume this huge volume of new
mortgages and new home ownership was
further exacerbated by the increasing
rise in home prices causing people to
refinance repeatedly take equity out
increase their overall leverage on their
home and this became like the most
perfect product in the world anybody who
ever touched it and apparently made
money on it so mortgages were this boom
for for the economy and you you know
combine that with a low interest rate
environment that we are in after 9/11
and you know Wall Street took to this
you know then all we did
since the 80s had been securitizing
loans but but this huge new volume of
mortgage financing resulted in a huge
new volume of asset-backed
mortgage-backed securities Wall Street
took to this with a passion
Bear Stearns Lehman Merrill all of them
really except for you know the the
smaller boutiques and they securitized
these things they packaged them up they
sold them off to hungry investors all
over the world who were hungry for yield
higher interest rate higher yielding
investments and of course these had been
rated in large part triple-a by the
rating agencies which was another big
problem here
and as these securities got sent all
over the world and Wall Street was
making huge fees for underwriting these
it was a great you know as his Chuck
Prince said you know you danced while
the music is playing the music started
to stop
you know people started warning about it
Paul Volcker warned about it in in
February of oh five at a speech at
Stanford and Meredith Whitney warned
about it at the end of oh five and her
writings that basically were in an asset
bubble in the mortgage area in the
housing area and as people found that
they had over leveraged themselves
couldn't pay the mortgages could never
have paid them in the first place the
performance of these mortgage-backed
securities started to decline and you
know Wall Street got stuck with huge
inventories of this product on their
balance sheet and you know laser
sulphate within Bayer there was one of
the gentlemen you still have in your
book throughout his Paul Friedman he
seemed to have sound some alarm bells
out there that he needed to raise
capital get out of some of these
positions why didn't anyone listen well
not only Paul but also Robert Upton as
well who was the treasurer of the firm I
think we're quite outspoken along the
way about saying you know we've got to
ratcheted up the leverage too much we're
we shouldn't be using one of Bob Upton's
continuous comments was where we're
using the cash balances of our hedge
fund clients and were you know taking
that money and using it elsewhere in the
firm that's called rehypothecation
which is a fancy way of saying you know
using somebody else's money to go invest
somewhere else and he kept saying you
know we shouldn't do this we should
raise capital and he's the one who was
you know meeting with the rating
agencies constantly and getting you know
the the vibe that you know Bear Stearns
was running too risky a business but I
you know I think that the problem is it
institutions sometimes across Wall
Street the executives get very insular
and insulated and a bear was no
exception I mean you think about it you
know there were only three guys who ran
that firm you know when it became a
meaningful firm until its his end it was
you know sy Lewis who ran it until his
death in 1978 there was a scream Berg
who ran it from 1978 until Jimmy deposed
him in 1993 and then Jimmy Kane from
1993 until January of o8 and Ace
Greenberg was still there he was still
on the executive committee still on the
board of directors still making
decisions along the way so it was really
these two guys who had this symbiotic
relationship that worked so well for so
long but you know they you know Jimmy
Kane was a bridge player and a broker
and didn't even graduate from college
not that that's neither here nor there
but he you know I don't think had a good
sense of how risky the firm had become
and I think that they both stayed in
their jobs too long I mean you know one
thing goldman sachs is better known for
is sort of pushing people out and
getting new blood into the executive
suite more regularly and I think firms
like Bear Stearns and Lehman Brothers
suffered greatly from not doing that
sooner one of the most chilling things
in the book is that bear actually had
liquidity despite the fact that it was
making these risky bets it had cash you
know they say on Wall Streeter have
confidence or you don't bear lost
confidence in a nanosecond what caused
the run on a bank well so on the one
hand they had this growing huge
inventory of risky securities and
mortgage-backed securities and
collateralized debt obligations that you
know in a in a better market they would
just manufacture and sell off but is the
I could slow down and and people didn't
want these securities as readily as they
had their inventory of these security
started to grow at the same time they
did something that very few people on on
Wall Street even people who work there
even understood I mean I I worked on
Wall Street for 17 years and it wasn't
until I started researching and writing
this book that I understood the way a
lot of Wall Street firms financed
themselves which is in this overnight
financing market this repo market and so
what they were doing and this is what
really killed them in the end because
they did have you know 18 closed 18
billion of cash on their balance sheet
what really killed them is that they
were taking these mortgage-backed
securities you know as a group and every
night using them as collateral with
overnight lenders to the tune of around
seventy five billion dollars so they
needed seventy five billion dollars
every night - you know finance their
business sort of sloshing around and
enabling them to do things and and they
had been rolling over the same 75
billion dollars for 20 years I mean or
not as much but it grew to that and this
has been something that Wall Street had
done for a long time and that final week
is you say when confidence started
slipping away and rumors started
circulating the overnight repo lenders
like fidelity investments are federated
began to get a little squeamish and they
thought well the risks aren't really
worth the reward here why should I
continue to make you know they did they
weren't being paid a lot for making
these overnight loans but you know I
want more collateral I want more
securities but as these mortgage
securities became worth less and less
you know became a vicious cycle downward
and finally federated in fidelity and
their ilk said we won't take those
securities as collateral we won't make
these overnight loans anymore we won't
even take your Treasury securities as
collateral so that became a you know a
death spiral because without that 75
billion coming in over the transom every
night morning they were forced to use
their own cash well you know by the time
people realized what was happening
everybody wanted their cash at the same
time and they very quickly ran out of
cash they they ran a cash
believe that Friday afternoon they
basically had to shut down the
department that allowed the cash to
leave the building they actually had you
know someone told me 78 billion of cash
actually there but it was all spoken for
and that to shut it down and they knew
that they would be you know bankrupt
Monday morning if they had opened again
you call your book house of cards and
the way you describe you know bears
funding operations it's it's sort of
amazing how Wall Street operates it's
kind of like a game of musical chairs
and all of a sudden the music stops and
they were caught out do you think Wall
Street needs to change the way it funds
itself the way it operates
I mean risk is a part of capitalism it's
a part of the way people have you know
made money on Wall Street for decades
but is there something fundamentally
wrong with the way Wall Street is
structured and operates in the way that
these banks have made money over the
years well there's certainly with
something very fundamentally wrong about
the you know relying so heavily on the
overnight funding market you know I
asked Gary Cohen the now co-president I
guess soon-to-be sole president of
Goldman Sachs is you know part of my
interviews for this book does Goldman do
the same thing there because they made a
fateful decision you know I guess it's
become a myth I assume it's true in
December of 2006 to get out of the
underwriting of mortgage-backed
securities and to short the index and
you know instead of losing a lot of
money on doing that business they
basically broke even and made money
shorting the index and Gary told me that
you know Goldman Sachs has a different
approach you know instead of you know
relying so heavily on the overnight
funding market they have maybe five
percent of their financing needs every
night in the overnight financing market
and they'd have more long-term financing
and I said to him well but that's cost
you more money right he said yes it cost
us a lot more money and so therefore our
net income is lower but it's worth it
because we don't have to you know give
these lenders a vote every night on
whether we can stay in business or not
well Bear Stearns took the opposite
approach and and one of the main reasons
is I write in my book is because that
executive committee of Jimmy Cayne and a
screen Berg and Warren Spector and Alan
Schwartz they got paid based on return
on equity calculation
which means you know maximizing the
profits of the firm with as little
capital as possible and one way to
maximize the profits of the firm was to
pay less for your financing costs so you
know and in fairness to these guys I
mean even though there was this element
of greed and they you know split 160
million dollars amongst them you know in
the last year that they got paid bonuses
which was you know for the year 2006 in
fairness to them this system had worked
you know like a charm for 20 years
but you know it's like anything you know
when the confidence is gone everything
that you thought worked you know no
longer works and at the end of the day
they were basically bailed out by the
government I mean bare ceased to exist
but talk a little bit about how that
happened the government essentially
forced bear into a merger with JP Morgan
Bear initially thought it was great that
they had 28 days to figure out how to
either fund themselves or sell
themselves it turned out they had
basically a weekend to figure out what
to do puts an 85 year old firm it went
from 28 days to 28 hours essentially and
it isn't incredible I mean and I
described it in the book how they found
out you know they knew they were in
trouble Thursday night and next thing
you know the SEC is there the Fed is
there the Treasury is there JP Morgan is
there but the Bear Stearns guys were
kind of kept in the dark in the early
hours of Thursday night and Friday
morning and they find out by an email at
6:45 in the morning from from JP
Morgan's league chief the general
counsel to to Bear Stearns general
counsel that basically they had been
rescued they literally thought they're
going to have to file for bankruptcy
Friday morning out of the blue comes
this 30 billion dollar facility that the
that the Treasury is lending or the Fed
I guess is lending to JP Morgan which is
in turn making that cash available to
Bear Stearns but there was no
documentation other than this press
release and the Treasury and the Fed
didn't put out a press release and
nobody knew how it was supposed to work
so initially you know my friend Paul
Friedman you know was euphoric because
they had been up all night wondering is
it they going to have to file for
bankruptcy and then they see this email
and they think they're saved in there
having everybody and everybody is really
excited and then they go upstairs and
try to convey their enthusiasm to the
traders who weren't part of the
all-night vigil and the traders are you
know freaked out they think this is the
worst thing in the world because it is
it gives evidence to how difficult and
precarious Bear Stearns situation is
that the Fed and the Treasury have to
step in at 5:00 in the morning to save
the firm well you know quickly Friday
became a disaster and then when the
rating agencies downgraded the firm
Friday afternoon you know it became
clear to everybody that and Paulson
especially that you know he wasn't going
to give them the 28 days that really had
been this amorphous concept it was never
documented and that's when he you know I
guess the metaphors put his foot on now
and Schwartz's throat and say you know
you need to get this done by Sunday
night or forget it
you mentioned treasurer secretary former
Treasury Secretary Henry Paulson current
Treasury secretary then New York Federal
Reserve President Tim Geithner and Fed
Chairman Ben Bernanke they were all
involved in basically forcing there to
marry JPMorgan they talked about how
there are some firms that are too big to
fail what were they so worried about why
didn't they just let their die well I
think as they got into it I mean I think
they were generally aware of how
interconnected all the relationships
were I mean you know Wall Street used to
be a relatively simple place of private
partnerships and you know working for
their customers but in the last
generation 25 years since they became
public companies and had much more
capital and many more relationships you
know this internecine web was spread out
all over the world and in large part
because of you know derivative contracts
and credit default swaps and these
mortgage securities that they had you
know sold to the to the to the four
corners of the earth and an investors
bought because they needed you know
wanted more yield than they could get
otherwise and so I think as they looked
at the book as they say as they looked
at the book of trading and the
relationships that Bear Stearns had
they decided at that moment again you
know not really sure how it was going to
play out over the next six months but
they decided that okay bear is too big
to fail or too interconnected to fail
because it really isn't too big to fail
it's just they were just afraid of the
you know domino effect that might happen
and you know they decided to see can we
find is there a suitor for bear and in
this instance they were fortunate that
JP Morgan and and really Jamie Dimon who
had you know been sort of courting Bear
Stearns for years on and off again when
he was CEO of Bank One and even when he
was a left Citigroup the first time you
know there was a match to be made and
and as you probably know on Sunday on
Saturday night early Sunday morning of
that weekend JP Morgan had walked away
after making an indication of 8 to 12
dollars a share they walked away and
then you know that's when the Fed came
in and said ok ok you know we'll take
these 30 billion of assets off you're
off Bears balance sheet and facilitate
the deal they were spooked by what they
saw in Bears books absolutely spooked
they thought the exposure was more than
then Bears books had indicated you know
of course the bear guys think that there
was just a form of negotiation and and
maybe it was so they saved bear yes they
let Lehman fail we're at the moment now
where AIG is in its third bailout from
the government paying out bonuses that
the government says they have no choice
but to allow and they're trying to
shrink this firm and sell it off with it
they can't let it fail because it's too
systemic the word they use does the
government have the right prescription
they save some firms they let others
fail they're worried about that you know
the tentacles the the global impact do
you think they know what they're doing
do you think they have the right ideas
about which firms to help which to which
to let die and also what to do to
prevent this from getting worse you know
that's what the $64,000 question I think
that you know you know is sort of a hard
comment to make because my gut is
telling me and it's sort of based on my
reporting and my research in my
and this will be you know this may get
me into trouble but I I think that at
each step of the way here that I kind of
believe that they did what they thought
would be the right thing at each moment
so based on the information that they
had I mean it's easy to look back and
say well how could you have done this or
that but I think they were you know
right to save bear I mean personally I
think that basically the firm was
bankrupt why they bailed out the
creditors because that's really what
they did why the creditors at bear and I
asked him goodness what why did you not
try to fashion some solution that would
have included the creditors making a
contribution instead of just the
shareholders instead of just the
shareholders and you know his answer was
what you might expect it's a good idea
but we didn't have time and I and I
understand that trying to corral a bunch
of creditors you know or putting a
tender offer in the paper - no - to
tender for the dead at 60 cents on the
dollar or whatever would have obviously
been much more complicated and then you
sort of fast forward - to the Lehman
situation and you know they're they made
a very different decision and I think
and you might know better than I but I
think you know you have began to have I
think some bifurcation amongst Paulson
Bernanke and and Geithner at least from
Geithner's perspective what he is said
to me is that you know he might have
been more willing to fashion sort of a
what became the AIG solution three or
four days later for Lehman had he known
he said that Barclays was not going to
do the deal for Lehman earlier in the
day earlier in the weekend he found out
on Sunday that the FSA the financial
services authority in the in the UK
which is similar to our SEC was not
going to allow Barclays to do that deal
had he found out on Friday he thought he
could have fashioned a different kind of
solution but again they ran out of time
and they ran out of time in these things
because of course they want to get a
solution before the markets open in Asia
and Australia I mean this everybody
knows this at this point but you'll bear
initially was sold for $2 which is just
a stunning number
I mean the stock was trading at 170
something just a few months earlier a
year a year earlier Hank Paulson the
former Treasury secretary was the one
who apparently pushed for a really low
stock price in the end bear got $10 talk
a little bit about what happened between
$2 and $10 there seemed to be a little
snafu you think these guys on Wall
Street is being so smart and yet
somebody screwed up correct and first of
all you know come a little interesting
anecdotes Jimmy Cayne told me that he
thought hank was actually pushing for $1
share at one point which never
materialized and and I tell a little
story about how Steve Schwarzman the CEO
Blackstone was was on Ron Perlman's boat
the Ultima 3 in st. Barths that weekend
and they got on their BlackBerry's the
$2 share you know news flash and they
both like everybody thought it was a
typo that it should be $20 a share
because the stock had traded in the 30s
you know close in the 30s of that Friday
afternoon but but the interesting thing
that happened was that that you know
Sunday night they had the press release
about the merger and the $2 a share and
that they also said that JPMorgan people
said they were going to you know
guarantee Bears trading and other
trading obligations you know forward
between the time of the announcement and
the deal closing in addition by the way
of course to you know paying 100 cents
on the dollar for all the debt and how
that guarantee worked became a matter of
misinterpretation and contention and I
think the bear guys quickly figured out
that it didn't wasn't going to work
exactly the way the JPMorgan people
lawyers Jamie Dimon has blamed it on the
lawyers at Wachtel the way they hoped it
would work and quickly the market began
to figure out that JP Morgan was going
to be on the hook for bears trading
obligations for at least a year you know
in the event that the bear shareholders
voted down the merger and this the way
the guarantee worked they were given the
incentive to vote it down so instead of
you know trading at or near the $2 a
share price which you would expect
the stat the stock try shot up to six
seven eight dollars a share and again
and clearly for the first time in a long
time
Bear Stearns had leverage against
JPMorgan to renegotiate the deal and
actually the irony is you know I think
that Alan Schwartz is a you know a great
guy and a great Emma a banker absolutely
the wrong guy to be the CEO of the firm
from January of o8 to March of o8 but
the absolutely right guy to be at the
firm during that weekend and to sell the
firm and he quickly understood for the
first time that the leverage that he had
as the CEO of Bear Stearns to recut the
deal with Jamie Dimon and that's what
happened and then next week culminating
on on Easter Sunday believe it or not
and I have this great quote from some of
the board of directors at Bear Stearns
who were at Easter Sunday service when
JP Morgan agreed to the ten dollar share
deal after having saying they wouldn't
change the deal and they of course
chalked it up to divine intervention um
why was the government so focused on
hurting the shareholders what what is it
about causing pain to the shareholders
why do we see shareholders getting
getting hurt well you know this is one
thing I actually agree with it with the
you know the government on I mean I
think basically the firm was bankrupt
when the firm is bankrupt shareholders
should get 0 or less than 0 and that's
the same I guess they can't get less
than zero so they can get zero but
that's the that's the calculation that
that the Board of Directors went through
when they deliberated about whether to
accept the two dollars I mean they knew
that in bankruptcy Sheryl's would get
zero and therefore didn't get any
benefit really from the government
getting involved right and I think you
know it was nice of them to agree to two
dollars I mean you know it could have
been if it had gone bankrupt then you
would have seen what happened to Lehman
and it would have been a nine cents on
the dollar deal for the creditors so I
think you know while everybody
complained and everybody was extremely
upset the two dollars looks pretty good
and then when it became ten dollars of
course you know for Jimmy Cayne you know
that was a you know like a 60 million
dollar you know payday and
I got a 45 million dollar change and he
was you know he should be thanking and
calling for that we're going to take a
quick break afterwards and several other
c-span programs are available for
download as podcasts more with William
Cohen and Deborah Solomon in a moment
here's a look at some upcoming book
fairs and festivals over the next few
months in April the Arkansas literary
festival goes to the River Market
district of Little Rock in Maryland the
Bethesda literary festival brings
Washington Post columnist Helen Thomas
and Michelle Singletary at the Annapolis
Book Festival Newsweek managing editor
Evan Thomas will reflect on the 2008
presidential election and Jim and Kate
Lehrer will discuss fiction writing
author and Olympic medalist era Taurus
will speak at the free library festival
in Philadelphia then in California the
LA Times Festival of Books book TV will
bring you live coverage of author panels
and interviews from UCLA and the annual
books in bloom festival welcomes readers
and writers to Eureka Springs Arkansas
please let us know about book fairs and
festivals in your area and we'll add
them to our list email us at book TV at
c-span org
afterwards with William Cohen and
Deborah Solomon continues you described
a scrappy underdog culture at Bear
Sterns maybe a lot of people don't know
that Bear Stearns was never considered
among the the white shoe firms like the
Merrill's and the Goldman's
it has a history of some pretty colorful
personalities you mentioned sy Lewis at
the beginning talked a little bit about
the culture and whether you think that
the fact that they were sort of the
underdogs of Wall Street influenced the
risk-taking that they took on and the
you know sort of the end for them yeah I
mean I think it's part and parcel of the
culture that they did view themselves as
underdogs I mean a when a screen burg
ran the firm he famously would issue
these memos to the employees on a
regular basis and in fact they've been
collected in a little book called memos
from the Chairman and you know these
memos sort of laid out the philosophy of
a screen burg a son of a Midwestern
women's clothing store merchants and you
know these homespun values and one of
the main ones that he took away from his
father was that you know when inventory
at the store isn't moving just mark it
down and get rid of it and that was the
same mentality and the same idea that he
took with him when he was running the
firm on Wall Street and at Bear Stearns
and the other ways that manifested
itself is he would encourage people to
reuse rubber bands and reuse paper clips
and only you lick one side of the
envelope so you could use it again and
live by licking the other side so you
know I think as a result you know in you
know to give to give a screen burg
credit when he was the CEO of the firm
it remained a small firm a very sort of
parochial in his interests and its
behavior and and made money consistently
year after year after year but but the
the vast talent of the people I think
was restrained to some extent because he
was very parsimonious with with capital
only gave capital to those businesses
where it was really Jen
raining returns which again makes total
sense but he wasn't creating you know
using risk capital he was probably
pretty risk-averse compared to to Jimmy
and one of the sort of dicta of the firm
was that you know he wanted what he
referred to as these PSD people poor
smart with a deep desire to become rich
so he himself you know had gone to
University of Missouri and Jimmy Cayne
had didn't graduate from Purdue and you
know it was a firm of sort of scrappy I
wouldn't say you know just totally
Midwesterners but but scrappy you know
guys coming to New York trying to make
it who knew that they couldn't get into
the white shoe firms and you know Jimmy
Cayne who you know his father was a
patent attorney and his mother was a you
know raised money for Jewish causes in
Chicago on the other side of Chicago he
you know he was a bit of a renegade in
college spend more time playing bridge
than studying he dropped out one
semester shy of his degree served some
time in the Army in Japan and then
basically just wanted to be a
professional British player and that's
why he moved to New York and it was
through playing bridge a bridge clubs on
the Upper East Side that he got to meet
sort of various titans of Wall Street
who would come after work to go play
bridge and the rules for Jimmy is a
professional British player with these
guys is you know don't question their
bridge playing don't comment on it I
mean if they're not very good don't say
anything and the last thing is of course
don't ask them about their business and
don't talk to them about business and at
one point he met a woman who had become
his second wife at one of these bridge
clubs and she said to him after a you
know whirlwind romance that you know it
you need to you know get a real job or a
new girlfriend and at that point he was
working as a bond salesman at Lehman
Thal and company the municipal bond
company in New York and he was you know
one of the most successful bond salesman
there but he was only putting like two
or three hours a day in and the
the time is playing bridge so he said
there you know Patricia I I I can't she
also offered to you know maybe we should
go to law school he said I can't go to
law school I didn't graduate from
college and you know he said well maybe
what I can do is use my bridge
connections to get an interview at bear
and Goldman and Lehman and that's what
he did and then ace hired him
basically on the spot during the
interview because he knew that Jimmy was
this great bridge player and a sort of
was a bridge aficionado but not nearly
of the level of it of Jimmy and he was
hoping that Jimmy would teach him how to
play bridge better and that's exactly
what happened and Jimmy came to to a
bear as a broker and quickly got uh you
know people like Larry Tisch as clients
which you know if you're a broker on
Wall Street at that time to have the
single largest investor in the market at
that time to be your client was great so
I mean it was in and then Warren Spector
of course was a bridge champion when he
was in high school and as he likes to
say he you know he didn't his success at
Bear Stearns had nothing to do with
bridge he was successful at Bear Sterns
before they even figured out he was a
great British player but it did lead to
his downfall at the firm which is kind
of interesting too yeah you know it's
interesting in the book bridge seems to
have built up Jimmy you know he got his
start as you mentioned by tapping those
bridge connections but at the end that
bridge playing seems to have really
damaged him his his reputation he was
AWOL during the firm's
you know final moments in fact had to be
called back from the bridge table to for
a crucial vote on whether the firm
should file for bankruptcy talk a little
bit about what happened where was he and
why wasn't he more focused on what was
going on at the firm that he helped
build you know in you know he it is
really important to point out that he he
did help build it I mean he I think he
unleashed all of this talent that was at
the firm to be more aggressive about
generating revenues now you know he
ended up they ended up generating
revenues that turned around to be you
know mistaken revenues but you know the
funny thing is that
Jenny really didn't change his behavior
the whole the whole time he was CEO I
mean playing bridge was always important
to him he would every year for at least
three weeks a year go off and play
bridge in these tournaments and they're
very intense you know no cell phones not
that he had one no blackberries not that
he had one but you know the the playing
was very intense and at the end of the
day you know he'd relax and unwind and
check in with the office and you know
and that management style where he
basically was sort of like the Joe Torre
managing a team of superstars you know
Warren Spector was a wunderkind and Alan
Schwartz was incredibly well regarded as
an M&A banker and and and it all seemed
to work pretty well I mean there were
you know troubles along the way like
with long-term capital and AR bear and
another you know incidents that got them
into trouble but Jimmy sort of managed
his way through that and and you know
the stock just took off it was like a
rocket ship when Jimmy took over I mean
I think it went from like $30 a share to
you know 170 to 69 it is big in January
2007 so you know nobody was questioning
the management style then of course when
problems started developing his
willingness to spend time you know even
change his behavior he kept playing
bridge he kept flying to the golf course
in the helicopter on Thursday night and
played no golf in Bridge all weekend I
mean it was fine until it wasn't that's
the problem and you know those final you
know the final days so to speak I mean
there was you know a telling incident
with bridge in in July right after they
had decided to liquidate the to hedge
funds in July of o7 both Jimmy and
Warren went off to play in a bridge
tournament Nashville now Jimmy that was
of the view that he had an agreement
with Warren that they both would not be
playing in these bridge tournaments at
the same time so you know when he would
see Warren at the bridge tournament you
know he said that Warren would avert his
gaze and and you know look away and
scurry away well that's so you know
upset Jimmy you know right on the heels
of liquidating the hedge funds which was
under Warne's purview
that that when he got back you know from
the British tournament he resolved to
fire Warren which he did you know at the
beginning of August
despite the you know members of the
board and other members of senior
management you know encouraging him to
change his mind
but Jimmy had made up his mind that
Warren had to go and that was a very
fateful decision because you know here
you have as the house of cards is
collapsing if you will
beginning to collapse you know you have
the architect not not around anymore and
that became you know I think a very
fateful decision you know fast forward
to March when the board is you know
Friday Thursday night is you know that
fateful week is deciding whether to file
for bankruptcy and you know Jimmy is in
Detroit playing bridge he's on the board
call initially and then he goes back to
the bridge table somebody asked him a
question but he's not there and then his
wife Patricia has to go Paulin back from
the bridge table and answer no questions
and then he flew back on on Saturday -
you know from Detroit to be you know at
the board meetings at the end but I mean
so on you know on the one hand he was
doing nothing different than he you know
always done and it had worked and and
see this is what we're I think it was
you know maybe important to for the
board to step in earlier and say you
know what we maybe need a succession
plan here that really works and yet
throughout the book Jim McCain is seen
as a loyal to Bear Stearns somebody who
wants to fight for its survival in fact
he talked about the nuclear option just
sort of saying to hell with it
letting the firm go into bankruptcy
which everybody knew would be a disaster
potentially disaster for the entire
financial sector for the global
financial market and yet he thought
about doing it but he didn't why not
well he thought about doing it because
he was so upset you know that the offer
was $2 a share he had just you know he
was doing mental gymnastics of his share
price times $2 a share he lost how much
money well he ended up losing about a
you know from its peak a billion dollars
in Bear Stearns stock now he was one of
the only CEOs on what he was the only
CEO on Wall Street worth more than a
billion dollars in his
that was a testament to how loyal he was
to the firm Hewitt II all the other
executives basically sold along the way
Jimmy kept most of his not that he
didn't sell some he did but he kept most
of it and you know at the end he decided
that you know you know to you know he's
very confrontational anyway I mean he
was the only Bear Stearns was the only
firm during the bailout of long-term
capital management not to participate
Jimmy had his reasons which I outlined
in the book which you know makes sense
to me but that made sure everybody was
quite pissed off at Bear Stearns as a
result of that come the end Jimmy was
going to be confrontational again you
know this is what they're going to give
us the hell with him well we'll push the
nuclear button you know spread nuclear
waste all over the world and bring
everybody else down well you know cooler
heads prevailed number-one bankruptcy
lawyers advised him that that was not a
very good idea and he would you know he
personally would open himself up to huge
liability and get a lot less money and
oh by the way the Board of Directors
which by this time had was beginning to
form itself into an independent board
for just this reason was never going to
vote for that so he he got that message
pretty quickly so you have Jimmy Cayne
the bridge player you've got a screen
Berg who as you colorfully mentioned
your book had an alter ego I won't even
try to pronounce the name but he will I
he would send out these memos these
emails with these you know like you
mentioned these homespun wisdom and you
know you have sy Lewis who died but was
sort of this irascible
angry you know erupt able man rational
football player right um these guys were
running a Wall Street firm
I mean you sort of shake your head and
wonder so they brought in people like
Alan Schwartz who in your book maybe
this isn't the right impression but he
seems just blindsided by everything that
happened and as you mentioned he maybe
wasn't the right guy to be running the
firm was the right guy at the end for
the M&A transaction but talk a little
bit about sort of how they brought
people in and and you know whether these
guys actually had you know the smarts or
the the ability to run this firm uh
people who came from the outside to Bear
Stearns
never did particularly well there I mean
you know all of Allen Schwartz or
inspector
ace and Jimmy and even sy Lewis you know
sort of grew up as professionals at Bear
Stearns and came of age and then you
know you know blossomed at Bear Sterns
people who came in from the outside to
try to suggest other ways to do things
you know burned out very quickly this is
very insular culture and for you know
you could see how they would want to
stick to that because it had worked well
for so long I mean they survived the
depression they survived World War two
they survived the crash of 87 you know
they they really didn't have you know
they had a very small role in the whole
you know research investment banking
crisis they had a bigger role in the
mutual fund crisis and paid a bigger
fine
you know they had little bumps along the
way you know even long-term capital you
know that didn't cost them anything
because I didn't participate basically
they paid a small fine relatively like
35 38 million dollars as a result of
what happened with AR Baron but you know
they kept sand meanwhile they're getting
more and more profitable every year
every quarter and and you know part of
the homespun charm that was in these
memos is oh by the way we're doing
things here in our own way our own a
conic clastic way that everybody else in
Wall Street isn't doing we're going to
stick to our knitting is working for us
don't let anybody you know try to
persuade you that we should be doing
things differently stick to what we're
doing stick to what works you know of
course when Jimmy came in in 93 you know
no more memos Jimmy that wasn't Jimmy
style he didn't manage that way he
managed by having people sort of come
into his office and seek his counsel and
I think he you know wanted to grow the
business he didn't want to you know as I
point out in the book he kept turning
down opportunities to you know expand
asset management business or expand
their their investment banking business
or they're clearing business you know he
had these little silos built up and he
kept funneling capital to the ones that
were making the most money and you know
Warren Spector you know made this
fixed-income business huge and you know
he prospered immensely and I think
very fateful decision which again which
Jimmy sort of prided himself on and this
is very much goes to the culture is
there was this what you know fairly
well-known guy named Howie Rubin who
learned about secured securitization
business from Lou Ranieri as Salomon
Brothers well you know Lou was the
Godfather of the securitization business
and you know over time Bear Stearns
won't compete with Salomon Brothers
Lehman want to compete with Salomon
Brothers Merrill wanted to compete with
Salomon Brothers at one point and by the
way you know Harry Rubin is written
about in Michael Lewis's book liars
poker so he's already had a little bit
of infamy and and he went from Salomon
Brothers to Merrill Lynch and at one
point he did this trade that to that
point was caused Merrill Lynch to lose
more money than had ever been lost
before by a single trader apparently and
the amount of money that he lost kept
getting changed you know first it was
like 300 million and by the end it was
much less but he got fired and you know
to find what he had done while he was on
vacation they had to take a chainsaw to
his desk and open up his drawers but
Jimmy who prided himself on recognizing
talent where other people didn't see it
and he did this throughout and by
promoting people like Warren Spector for
instance above other people
he decided that Howie Reuben was going
to be was great and wanted him at Bear
Sterns he turned you know and in many
ways he was right Howie Rubin turned
into an ideal employee he was much
better supervisors at Bear Stearns and
he'd been at Merrill and he grew but he
what he did is he grew this
mortgage-backed security business
he hired more people he managed it they
became immensely profitable Bear Stearns
was one of the leaders in doing the
first securitization and over time
became the leaders in securitization and
that another another fateful decision
that Jimmy just sort of plucked this guy
and you know he gave him some capital
and it started working and they gave him
more and it kept working and you know
it's sort of like a bit of it like a
seat-of-the-pants kind of operation
which worked until it didn't did the
rank-and-file blame Jimmy did I think he
was to blame for what happened to the
firm
ah I think yes I mean you know I I don't
talk you know Paul Friedman talks about
how you know you know one of the myths
about all of this is that you know it
was a tsunami that came and washed on
our shores and washed away all the
firm's nothing that could have been done
about it Paul Friedman you know who was
the chief operating officer of the fixed
income group and worked for all the
heads of fixed income for the 25 years
he was there said no we did this to
ourselves and you know that's that rare
wonderful moment of honesty and
integrity that I just loved because he
was willing to say what really happened
and and I think that that's what the
book is really about it's about
explaining to people how Bear Stearns
did this to themselves how Lehman did
this to themselves how Wall Street how
we did this Wall Street did this to
itself and that's I think the real
message that that the book contains at
the end of the day though there are
regulators there are people that are
supposed to be overseeing this we had
corporate accounting scandals post Enron
we were supposed to have much more
engaged boards we were supposed to have
better you know enforcement at the SEC
the Fed was supposed to be more engaged
yes what exactly right I mean was there
something that the regulator's missed
something here or were were the rules
you know post glass-steagall which
allowed these banks to get bigger and
bigger take out more leverage were these
rules just you know were they headed for
disaster because these firms were
allowed to take on so much leverage
essentially what Bear Stearns was doing
was completely legal completely and then
and I'm sure you referring to what the
June 2004 SEC ruling that allowed the
investment banks to take on more
leverage than they were already in
exchange supposedly for more oversight
and regulation which unfortunately never
happened I mean I don't think I'm a
maybe this is directionally correct I
don't think there was anyone from the
SEC in Bear Stearns offices until you
know that fateful August weekend after
the hedge funds had blown up when they
fired Warren Spector and no KKR was also
there and thinking about putting an
investment and in the third room the SEC
was there meeting with Paul
going over the books I mean where had
they been all the rest of the time and
you know things like taking out the
uptick rule which you know many people
feel exacerbated the downward pressure
on stocks you know and it's Tim Geithner
said to me look I was not the supervisor
of Wall Street right I was a supervisor
of banks the SEC I mean I don't think he
was trying to deflect responsibility I
think he was just making clear that we
wanted people to made to understand that
that that the SEC was Wall Street's
regulator now that has changed because
Wall Street is you know no longer more
investment no more investment banks and
they become bank holding companies those
that exist and so the regulation has
changed but I mean I think it's fair to
say and you know I don't know why in
particular we'll have to wait for for
other books maybe from your colleague
David Wessel why you know the SEC you
know dropped this ball so completely for
so long and then let these firms sort of
run while I mean the leverage was
obscene I mean you know at the end of
the quarter they maybe they were
reporting 35 or 31 but intra quarter was
up at 50 to one I mean while commercial
banks were at what 10 to 10 10 to 1 and
yet you talk about Tim Geithner not to
let him off the hook too easily I mean
Citigroup was under his his watch
you know the commercial banks and yet
they've run into problems too and maybe
they're not as highly leveraged but they
were having their own issues it seems
like Washington just sort of missed the
ball what has to happen what do we need
to see to make sure this doesn't happen
again and will we have we ever have a
Wall Street that like we used to have
yeah
well I think part of the way we have a
Wall Street like we used to have is for
Wall Street to remember what it used to
be like and go back there you know what
they were really good at I mean not
saying the private partnership world
should return although some of that is
happening I mean the rise of these new
boutiques is fascinating to watch and
you know Wall Street used to be these
small boutiques until they became big
too so we may be seeing you know the
first shoots of a new Wall Street coming
here but in terms of sort of the legacy
Wall Street or the zombie Wall Street
whatever you want to call it I think
they need to go back and I think they
recognize this I mean the people I
talked to who work on Wall Street or
what you
Wall Street still recognize they have to
go back to doing what they're good at
raising capital for their clients
you know anywhere in the world that they
need it giving advice on on M&A deals or
asset management and you know maybe a
little less financial innovation would
go a lot further here and it's
inevitable that the regulation is coming
you know I think it's ironic that that
Paulson sort of issued his presidents
working group report the same week that
Bear Stearns ran into trouble and you
know how that we any buddies mentioned
the words president's working group
report in the year since I mean but it's
sitting there there's a blueprint I know
Geithner's you know once he gets past
all the other issues he's got is focused
on it Bernanke is focused on it so the
regulation is coming and you know it's
going to come down like a ton of bricks
but I think ironically Wall Street is
sort of with with the notable exceptions
of AIG and Merrill Lynch which I'm not
quite sure what was going on in either
of those firms and why they were so
clueless
but but I think Wall Street is getting
the message that they're in the
spotlight now they're in the crosshairs
and they better you know change their
behavior and the way they've worked
unfortunately it takes a crisis like
this which is so devastating so
devastating for them to get the message
and then I worry about you know whether
they do really get it and this will be
like a permanent change because you know
I started on Wall Street in September of
1987 and literally a month later we had
the decrepit crash in the market
twenty-two point six percent decline in
the Dow in one day I saw a grown man cry
you know lamenting their fates and how
can we ever let this happen again and
then you had the commission that was
appointed the Brady Commission to study
that and here's the market mechanisms
we're not going to let this happen again
and you know how many times has it
happened again since then so you know
while it seems that everybody's getting
the message right now what do we need to
put in place and I don't have the answer
to make sure that these things don't
happen again because I don't think it
happened quite nearly as much when when
Wall Street was a series of private
partnerships where the partners shared
liability with one another for what
happened as
sharing the benefit but when they
started going public and the incentives
changed so that that the employees who
are taking out between 50 and 60 cents
on every dollar of revenue generated
what other business in the world does
that you know their incentive was to
take the short-term risks with their
shirt holders money so they could get
paid their big bonuses and have no
accountability attached to it that
obviously hasn't worked so maybe we'll
get back to a simpler era there's so
much outrage towards these banks you
know so much outrage from the American
people from Congress everywhere you go
you hear people talking about just the
fact that these firms have gotten
bailouts they should be allowed to die
how important is it to have a big
financial sector I mean the financial
sector has become such a big part of our
economy can we survive with a smaller
one and should we should Wall Street be
much smaller than it is well you can if
you look to the history used to be a
small part of our economy then it got to
be the largest part of our economy now
it's shrunk down again and you know as
have other sectors of the economy
I think if Wall Street again sticks to
what it's best at providing advice where
it's asked for and people willing to pay
for it and raising capital around the
globe I mean that is really what Wall
Street is about and should be about and
if that means it's not the largest
sector of our economy so be it if that
means there's a little less financial
innovation and a little less risk-taking
and you know what maybe fewer 30 year
olds who come to Wall Street to push
paper around and think that they can
make you know five million dollars by
the time they're 32 I think we're better
off what was the most interesting or
unusual thing you learned in researching
your book well I think that that
discovering because you know having
worked on Wall Street for 17 years I
just didn't know this discovering how
Wall Street financed itself I don't even
think the CEOs of many Wall Street firms
realized in the treasurer's did the CFOs
knew but you know to put yourself at
risk to the tune of 75 billion dollars a
night in the overnight financing markets
so that you give Fedele a vote I mean
how can you give fidelity a vote every
night about whether they're going to
keep doing business with you is that
something you think the government
should curtail
I think them I think the market is
already tanking I don't think the
government has to do that at all
because it's already happening I mean
you know there I mean then what Goldman
was supposedly doing is what now they're
on my doing and don't forget now they've
got access to the Fed window this this
is all in an era and this is one of the
damaging things that that taking away
glass-steagall did it it basically
allowed the commercial banks to comedic
compete in the same lines of business as
the investment banks but knowing that
they had access to the Fed window so the
poor investment for the investment banks
had to you know compete against these
people but without that axis so they had
to gin up these other forms of financing
and you know they chose this overnight
route because it was so inexpensive
which boosted their profits along with
their the amount of leverage they were
taking it was a series of decisions made
over many years
day after day that you know made by the
executives of these firms that's why
they got into trouble not because of
some you know unknown boogeyman they got
into trouble because they were the
incentives they were given were for you
know they get more pay if they have more
profits which was probably a good thing
right that's what they're supposed to be
doing but the question is they just took
way too much risk to do it with other
people's money and they got all the
rewards